Richard Corcoran Speaker of the Florida
House he signed a letter calling for
Israel suspension as sheriff of Broward
County and he joins us tonight the
speaker thanks coming up no thanks for
having me on I appreciate Duggars show
tell us what your letter says and why
well Bay and first it wasn't just a
letter from me it was a letter from me
and 73 of my colleagues basically
representatives accountable for 13 plus
million people in the state of Florida
and what we sent a letter to the
governor saying under the Constitution
he has the right to remove any local
government official suspend them and and
take them out of office and we said
basically your authority to do so as if
their malfeasance misfeasance
incompetence neglect of duty of which we
believe that sheriff Israel scores high
on all four counts so we asked him to
suspend him and go down there and take
over the investigation and find a
replacement and so 74 of us signed it
the governor immediately to his credit
called on FDLE our state law enforcement
agency to go down there and cease the
investigation and take over but we'd
still like to see him suspended by the
governor and then ultimately our Florida
Senate has the ability to reinstate him
or have him be removed completely and
I'm pretty sure talking to my colleagues
in the Senate they'd remove him
completely
so my guess would be of the 74
signatories most or all were Republicans
which raises the question why is this a
partisan issue so he had four deputies
with guns at the scene of a school
shooting and they refused to help that's
not a partisan question you need to be a
Republican to be appalled by that why
did no Democrats support his removal
well I think we do have the support you
know it's very difficult I think for
some of them because many of them are
from that geographical area of Broward
County right a significant portion of
our Democratic colleagues so I think for
them it was like you're right go forward
we encourage you but you know signing
the the letter was was something that
was a step too far for them but but
they're completely supportive whether
it's the parents I've talked to of the
victims whether it's our colleagues
across the aisle
everyone's disgusted with both his
attitude and the investigation and what
he's been doing stood today so my
impression is that the deputies who sat
outside armed while 17 people were
murdered at the school were within their
legal rights they were allowed to do
most of us respect law enforcement
because we think they're willing to put
their lives in the line for us these
people weren't that seems to me may be
something that the legislature could
address if you're a deputy in charge of
protecting the public
shouldn't you be obligated to protect
the public yeah and let me say Tucker
and I think you would say the same thing
I'm an outside counsel for a sheriff's
office as part of my job as an attorney
I can tell you the sheriff's a friend of
mine I know tons of law enforcement
officers not one single law enforcement
officer that I know in that situation
wouldn't have gone scrambling into that
hallway thank the stairways whatever it
took to try to save those children what
we have here is a poorly run agency and
whether it was the the officer on-site
or the the three that came in the car or
the the officers that went out to his
house as you said 23 times and never did
anything even though he was a threat
whether it was the deal that he entered
into with the superintendent schools
that basically said we're gonna have a
no arrest policy so he can bring guns
and knives and bullets to school all of
these things and and and the funny thing
is is this is by his own words what
sheriff Israel said is in each one of
those situations the officers outside
the school resource officer inside the
the people inside who denied first
responders the ability to go help these
kids the the in agreement and and those
bullets coming to school he's got every
single person under investigation but he
just want to hold himself accountable
for all these people that he has to
investigate for their wrongdoing but
he's done none and the height of
arrogance as you said Tucker I mean the
only amazing thing about Europe is real
is his arrogance I mean something that
song it seems like this is not normal
behavior but but quickly in the military
there's no sanction a penalty for
cowardice because the point is you're
not allowed to be a coward you're in the
military and I think the same would go
wouldn't you say for a sheriff's deputy
or any law and foremost aren't cowards
but for those who are shouldn't there be
some penalty for that there should I
mean we should look at taking away their
pensions if you don't act the way you
should in a situation where there are 14
children's lives at stake in three
adults absolutely you should have your
pension taken away good thank you for
that
speaker cork and I appreciate it coming
on tonight